puede boris johnson seguir al frente del
gobierno británico esa pregunta se ha
vuelto cada día menos tabú las últimas
acusaciones el daily telegraph reveló
que downing street estuvo de fiesta en
la víspera del funeral del príncipe
felipe de edimburgo el año pasado esa
misma noche la reina isabel estuvo sola
de luto debido a las reglas de
confinamiento un acto por el que este
viernes la oficina de johnson pidió
disculpas pero que no logró calmar los
ánimos incluso entre sus propios colegas
conservadores de igual calibre hacen que
creo que como todo aquel que leyó esta
historia esta mañana me sorprendió me
sorprendió leerla subir a este es un
momento particularmente sombrío por
supuesto para todos por todo nuestro
país toda la nación compartió con su
majestad su vestir y creo que los
eventos que tuvieron lugar esa noche
fueron totalmente inaceptables y
completamente insensibles y nunca
debieron haber sucedido roger gay está
entre varios parlamentarios que han
confirmado públicamente su intención de
castigar a johnson si el 15% de los
diputados conservadores lo hace habrá un
voto de censura que puede terminar con
su expulsión pero downing street-
sugiere a los británicos furiosos por lo
sucedido
pasar la página
el primer ministro se disculpó el
miércoles fue muy claro en cuanto a que
se han cometido errores pero sí creo que
debemos analizar la posición general en
la que nos encontramos como país creo
que debemos seguir adelante y hablar
sobre cómo vamos a resolver nuestros
problemas
boris johnson reconoció haber asistido a
una fiesta en mayo de 2020 argumentando
que pensaba que era un evento de trabajo